Nicki Minaj's opening tonight I love
Nikki right gonna be great gonna be
great
you've heard truffle butter right oh
yeah okay you know what truffle butter
is exactly what it is truffle butter
yeah you know what it is I don't think I
do
you have a really becbs luck right now
I've looked it up all right
sorry I did I was like oh okay oh my god
we were just talking about this in the
car my brother told me the definition of
my brother is 15 how does he know this
you know kids these days we brought some
truffle butter to the carpet today for
everyone to try we figured snacks might
be in order
yeah yeah do you want to try some well I
don't know if I might get all in with my
seat but what not if you want white or
black truffle butter apple rebeccablack
should have flashes yeah that's not even
a question give it a wet oh that's bad
smells excellent oh there's the little
whip oh it'll ruin you for the rest of
the night Rebecca okay I'm a little
nervous I'm a little excited I want you
to taste I want you to tell me what they
should think about a little garlic
I love the creamy um nicely dream you
really got potent if I licked a butt
crack oh that's why what it would taste
like Wow
is that your girl yeah it's 2015
Remington so I'm not a fan you know not
a man I'm not gonna another life you
don't like our truffle butter I'm pretty
disappointed in BuzzFeed right now I'm
sorry
oh I'll dip it and feed it to you stick
out that tongue oh my god I can't
believe we're in love get up a lot of
that truffle yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah so you like both of our truffle
butters I do great to hear but what is
truffle butter really cuz now you guys
are making me seem dirty oh I was
talking about the porn version of
Ruffalo what are you talking about this
obviously this is what Nicki Minaj is
singing about the delicate treat of
trouble but it's a high-class
delicacy absolutely not